diese wörter diese worte möchte ich an
die staatsbürger belarus
heute sind sie alle aufgerufen in einem
referendum zustimmen das könnte als ein
ganz normaler politischer prozess
aussehen aber heutzutage gibt es nichts
mehr normales heute werden andere
entscheidungen getroffen von ganz
anderer tragweite
vergangenen nacht war grausam mal wieder
beschüsse mal wieder ballon von
wohnvierteln zivilen infrastruktur
es gibt momentan in unserem land kein
objekt welches der autobahn nicht als
ein ziel anvisiert hatte die okkupanten
kämpfen gegen alle
gegen alle lebewesen gegen kindergärten
gegen wohnhäuser und sogar gegen franken
waren sie setzten reaktiviert ellery
infrastruktur das geocachen ihr gern
somit und viele andere orte sind ukraine
müssen dass unter den bedingungen
überleben die man
auf unserem land und auf ihrem land noch
im zweiten weltkrieg herrschten
im krieg die heute bei uns stoppt haben
wir sie nicht auf unserer seite leider
von ihrem staatsgebiet sky
programme starten die
russischen streitkräfte die raketen auf
uns von ihnen aus werden unsere häuser
zerstört alles wird in der luft
gesprengt was in den letzten jahrzehnten
aufgebaut worden ist und zwar nicht von
nun sondern von unseren eltern und
großeltern
und das ist auch de facto einer
referendum für sie lieber belarus nie
jetzt müssen sie entscheiden wer sie
sind und was sie
werden möchten wie sie ihnen die augen
von ihren kindern schauen werden sich
einander und auch ihren nachbarn und
wir sind ihre nachbarn da sind wir
und nicht russland diese entscheidung
sollen sie ausgerechnet heute treffen
heute hört man viele meldungen über
eventuelle verhandlungen die schluss mit
diesem krieg machen könnten und in
diesen gesprächen auch sehr oft ihre
hauptstadt minsk auf als verhandlungsort
aber dieser verhandlungsort haben nicht
wir ausgewählt
und eigentlich auch nicht
verlassen sondern die russische führung
und jetzt haben wir den vorschlag
bekommen bei uns bei ihnen zu treffen
aber seit
44 tagen werden von ihrem staatsgebiet
die raketen auf unsere wohnhäuser
abgefeuert
von ihrem land fährt die schwerer
militärtechnik in die ukraine rhein
wissen sie kia wurde um vier uhr
angegriffen und vier uhr da muss man
schon ein
besonderes gefühl für humor haben hier
wurde angegriffen
1941 auch um 4 uhr
sie schlafen immer noch lieber
belarussen und wir gehen sei derzeit
nicht ins bett weil wir stehen im kampf
für unser land
für unsere freiheit und darauf haben wir
unser gutes recht
da gibt es
keine aggressive
angriffe von ihrem staatsterritorium
geben könnten wir bei ihnen verhandeln
das haben wir aber auch frühjahr gemacht
und das war ganz in ordnung und das war
richtig so geht es unter guten nachbarn
heutzutage aber
haben sie ihre wahl noch nicht getroffen
sie steht unmittelbar bevor und sie soll
ausschließlich von ihnen abhängen nicht
von amerika oder russland ausschließlich
von dem volk von pilatus deshalb
ist minsk für uns
inakzeptabel wir streben nach
verhandlungen egal wo wasserpest
bratislava istanbul baku dass solche
vorschläge haben wir russland
unterbreitet eigentlich für uns wäre
jeglicher stadt
akzeptabel hauptsache in einem land von
vorher unserer städte nicht angegriffen
werden immer nur so könnten die
verhandlungen ehrlich verlaufen
von ganzem herzen möchte ich den ihrem
land wünschen wieder zu einem
liebenswerten land werden wie belarus
früher war sie müssen dieser wichtige
wahl heute treffen
und das wäre die wichtigste wahl des
russischen volkes